each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available so we have a a great session
um now uh the previous session was was
really interesting to hear what the the
research Community was doing uh this
session is uh flipping it the other way
really and um talking a bit about what
we're doing here in Microsoft and
Microsoft research um and on both the uh
sort of infrastructure side and also um
on some of the research side here as
well so uh great pleasure to be
introducing David here who works for an
organization called Global Foundation
Services um that runs Microsoft's uh
sort of infrastructure across the world
um and I think this is you know I've
seen his slides it's a great great
insight into what powers uh Powers
Microsoft really um so thanks kji so uh
thanks thanks for having me thanks for
the interest in in the the topic today
um my name is Dave gothier I run our our
data center architecture group in global
Foundation Services um really
responsible for the technical strategy
and the availability profile of the
physical data centers we we we build
around the world um I'm probably the
only person in this room who doesn't
have some sort of degree in computer
science so go easy on me um
but I've been in the company about 15
years and what we find a lot in the data
center physical industry is that people
just kind of fall into this space my
background is in a little bit of
computer science a little bit of um
broadcasting and Communications and just
a a love of wires and plugging things in
and and so kind of fell into this space
um but yeah really want to talk about
the the growth that the growth of the
cloud and how that's fueled our
investments in data centers around the
planet um and and kind of how we tackle
that so uh Microsoft is a lot of people
know runs a lot of different cloud
services we've we've actually got you
know the probably the five big ones that
everybody talks about or knows about
Office 365 Windows Azure uh Hotmail
Windows services and the things that
power the back end of of Windows 8 uh
bing and and the Xbox Live components
but there's there's about 200 different
services that make all this up we're
delivering to over a billion customers
around the world 20 million businesses
and and hitting a ton of markets in a
ton of different languages uh around the
globe
the main point of this there's some
really big numbers here billions and
trillions um but it's really more about
the scale and the need that we've had to
scale over the last probably four or
five years since things really started
ramping up and to take something like
Office 365 which is the fastest growing
product in Microsoft history we're
moving all these folks on Exchange and
SharePoint into the cloud as a service
uh we need to be building data centers
and new markets all the time we need to
be innovating in our data center space
and then for Windows app aure where
there's a robust competition uh for uh
IAS and P services in the cloud we need
to be able to do that a very very
competitive rates and be able to do it
very very quickly and agile and so
building new data centers innovating in
their efficiency and in their cost to
deliver uh is key to to doing
that around the world these are kind of
the Big Data Centers we talk about um I
think we have a number of presences here
in in North America uh we're also up new
services in Asia and China around Office
365 and and Azure lighting up uh
Australia and Brazil as well a lot of
people ask what goes into the selection
how do we decide where to place data
centers and really it's it's about it's
about 35 things we used to like to call
it 31 Flavors and then it grew um but
it's about proximity customers it's
about the usage and the utilization and
the speed and latency that these
services are consumed under uh you know
a lot of cases we have customers come to
us and say hey why isn't there a data
center in my town it's like well I could
build a data center right next door to
your office building but in reality both
of these are going to Transit all the
way back to Amsterdam before they come
back here um and so having real
proximity to the customers from a
network standpoint is super
key having robust scaleout energy and
fiber infrastructure is another really
important element these data centers are
getting into the tens of megawatts uh of
capacity we're going into a lot of rural
locations that have lots of land that we
can expand that we can keep growing and
growing and growing without having to
start on a new site so having an energy
grid that we can support that from is
really key and having growth in fibers
key and the last piece is uh around the
skilled Workforce you know people who
can build these data centers we're we're
turning up you know hundreds of millions
of dollars of projects in very short
amount of time so we need to build them
and then we need to operate and and run
them and take care of the servers and
the electrical mechanical equipment
inside the data
centers we've been on a bit of a a
journey
um and I've been involved with this kind
of kind of I want to call it day one we
built our First Data Center at Microsoft
in 1986 um it's about half a mile that
way it still exists it's called building
11 um and it was really about corporate
it functions but we built our first like
internet facing data center in 96 um
that's North a little bit uh in in
Bothel
and when we really started going into
the Internet space after 96 97 98 99
through about 200
2002 we're really going out and buying
collocation third party uh leasing space
and and growing into that I think the
main reason I talk about this is because
those stuff was just about rent it was
just about a place to put your servers
and put your devices and run them a lot
of companies still run this day today or
this way today um and there was never
much thought of efficiency or Energy
Efficiency or resource efficiency in
those types of data centers because
they're fully landlord tenant
relationships who cares what the tenant
pays I'm just going to build this thing
and we have this metric we call Pue it's
a very very it's an overly simplistic
metric um but it's one that people can
grock easily um that's about efficiency
so it's about the amount of energy
coming into the building versus the
amount of energy being consumed at a
compute resource or device or network
device so it's a simple simple uh
overhead metric and it's a good way to
talk about things in 2007 um we had
eaten up all of the extra leas space of
the com boom had afforded us and we
realized we need to start building data
centers ourselves this the first time we
really focused on designing for
efficiency designing for operation and
how we actually deploy in the
environment and get get a little bit
more speed into what we were doing and
we were able to knock a number of points
off of a off of the Pu metric straight
away just by focusing on it as an owner
rather than as a
tenant in generation three started
Landing in 2009 we played with
containers and I think a lot of people
probably heard about or have heard about
containerized data centers um and we we
really went all in on this we built a
very large facility in Chicago where we
were
deploying container 40 foot shipping
containers filled with servers we get
about 2,000 machines into each box we
could roll it in off a truck and within
about eight hours we'd have our bits
imaged on top of that and we'd be
serving traffic off of that cluster uh
highly highly efficient from a workflow
and a and a scale standpoint and also
highly efficient from an energy and a
water
uh consumption standpoint so it was just
a super big win-win the other element
that we brought in to that container
Farm is the first time we looked at what
we call differentiated slas so the
typical data center environment today if
you were to go and hire somebody to
build your data center they're going to
build it to 5 9's availability really
quick you know very low meantime or
sorry very high meantime between failure
very low meantime to recover and it's
always running you can treat it as a
permanent resource now we know as
software developers and as service
Developers that there are a whole bunch
of other things that can go wrong
besides just the power going out on the
infrastructure and so if we want to
design our applications better we're
going to design them for all the faults
that can happen in the system and so we
took advantage of that just you know
five years ago and actually provided a 3
n environment for our server
infrastructure and recognizing it can
fail and they have failed um in in one
instance we took a double lightning
strike um on two separate substations
that connect this data center and those
data those servers didn't have any
generators behind them and so we dropped
tens of thousands of machines great
thing is we've got some smart people
here nobody outside of Microsoft noticed
the applications kept running the users
were available everything went as
actually was supposed to happen it was a
lot of operational work on the other
side to recover the environment but we
we got there and we learned from it so
you do have five9 yeah five 9es at the
service right five9 at the service three
NES or less at the
infrastructure we took this a little bit
further in our generation 4 facil fa
ities and these are what we are we're
still turning over a number of these
facilities today um and we we moved more
of those modular components into into
containers and we also took advantage of
outside air to cool them so they were
even more efficient and they used a heck
of a lot less water about 1% of the
water of this St of my wayist pointer is
not on there this data center versus
this data center huge reduction in the
amount of the water that was
consumed and that's really about you
know fast time to Market and sizing
across to our
demand now what am I working on today uh
working on our Gen 5 infrastructure and
we're uh just announced um investments
in Cheyenne Wyoming and Deo Iowa West de
Mo Iowa um of nearly half a billion
dollars for for new data center
construction this is our gen five uh
builds that are kicking off this is
about integration this is taking that
understanding of the service and the
application another layer deep into the
infrastructure where we're designing the
data center the server the network the
workflow and operational tooling all
together with Windows Azure and with the
the team behind Bing autopilot which I
think we've talked about a fair amount
in the
past it's really about resilient
software so the software can deal with
any kind of failure within the
environment it's on common
infrastructure we have much fewer uh
server products or SKS than we've had in
the past and it's really about being
flexible and scalable so we can get all
the benefits we had here with an
integrated system we're able to kind of
rev the code of the data center you know
kind of compile the availability to be
what the service needs to
run one of the things that goes into
that and this is a e science Workshop so
I figured I'd try to least show you some
of the some of the math we put behind
this stuff um you know we we're running
over a million servers so that means we
have a really nice big sample pool to
pull from for how infrastructure runs
and one of the most notable and simple
things that we did with this is we we
modeled out our data center topologies
in the temperatures outside and the
temperatures inside and what the weather
was doing against the device failures um
on the systems and the number one thing
that fails in in big infrastructure is
hard drives uh number one number two
thing is systems that support hard
drives and I don't remember what number
three is but it's way down the list
after those two and so we were able to
find that depending on the the inlet
temperature that the DAT that the device
was seen we could annual look at our
annualized failure rates and really
understand understand how hot we could
run the data center and so we took this
information we've poured it into the
designs we're running our data centers
10 to 32 degre C with a Time weighted
average of 24 de
c um to uh to get the best Energy
Efficiency possible out of this this has
actually driven our pu numbers down on
that last slide from the uh you know
from the 1.2 to the
1.07 uh range uh mostly in in hard drive
temperature knowledge
also done a lot of other things removed
all the unnecessary components you know
no heart no spinning sorry no CD ROMs no
USB ports things like that but we're
also running at a European voltage now
we're running one voltage across our
portfolio 415 volts it's the most
efficient we're able to take extra
Transformations out of the design and
we're able to have uh commonality in our
supply chain worldwide as a
result um let's see the other piece is
around from these high temperatures how
we get that major savings is by using
outside air cooling we use uh what's
called adiabatic cooling or direct
evaporative like if you're sitting on
the beach and you've got a spray bottle
and you sprit yourself that's how we
cool our servers we open the windows and
we spray a little bit of of moisture
into the air to bring the temperature
down on the super hot days by
introducing humidity so it's super super
efficient uh we've got these running
almost around the world there's only a
few locations where we can't do this
most of that's in Southeast Asia where
it's very humid at the same time it's
very
hot the other interesting pieces that we
working on the next next uh elements uh
we've got a team working on Research
around uh direct sorry um distributed
generation and also fuel cells now we've
got a A Team uh at MSR and GFS and along
with the uh UC Irvine uh National Fuel
Cell Research Center working on directly
powering servers off of natural gas and
so we have a rack of servers where we
we're converting natural gas uh via a
I'm going to get caught on this one I
think it's a pem fuel cell um to
actually deliver direct DC voltage into
the servers and this is going to this
has been really really successful it's
really exciting because if you know the
grid is horribly inefficient at
delivering energy something like 40 to
60% of the input energy is actually lost
in the distribution before it comes into
a Data Center and so if we can take
Natural Gas straight straight into the
data center we're able to run a
tremendously higher efficient data
center uh infrastructure overall so this
is one of my favorite things that we're
working on other piece we're actually
taking that a step further and in
Cheyenne we're working with um uh with
local University on a waste water
treatment plant where we're recovering
methane gas coming off of this treatment
plant and we're then running that into a
fuel cell to run servers and so we could
see ourselves um you know all jokes
aside kind of powering these things off
poop um which is pretty pretty exciting
um see the other nice thing about this
is that there's a lot fewer Parts a lot
fewer things break and so the
reliability of the system increases
fewer broken fewer moving Parts fewer
broken pieces um and we're able to have
a common system again worldwide where
all we need is a natural gas feed and
we're ready to go
um and so just to summarize I'm couple
minutes over but um the other the other
element that we're really working on in
Microsoft is Shifting the thinking I
think there's been a lot of talk about
one Microsoft and about
um doing things at Cloud scale and
really thinking about new ways of
developing apps new ways of delivering
services and so these are kind of key
themes that when I talk to developers
here I'm really nailing on a daily basis
you need to think about resilient
Services how is your app going to deal
with not only a power failure or cooling
failure but also somebody fat fingering
the code into the uh into the into the
the router how are you going to recover
from that so these brittle these brittle
services and brittle networks need to
start getting stronger solve Hardware
problems in software software company we
don't need to solve we don't need to
throw a bunch of redundancy or extra
components at the problem let's figure
out how to how to solve that um
self-healing and last piece is probably
the more critical element in scaling how
are we enabling the business um we need
to be able to go out and come up with
new products the data center and the
servers and the network are not the
product that Microsoft sells the the key
thing that we're looking at doing here
is making sure that that infrastructure
is there to enable de developers enable
researchers to be able to spin up new
ideas Test new hypotheses and get them
out to Market faster or or uh or solve
that problem so that's about it there's
some slides there some content here on
the back end that people are welcome to
go out and check out we've got a robust
blog at microsoft.com La data centers
and a whole bunch other great
information on Azure and
0365 there any yeah questions please I
should have said ask me questions as I
go I forgot that part number
one I just know how using S D change
that in the system of course there's
additional cost but when it comes
to yeah absolutely so the question was
how do how does um how does hard drives
being the number one failure change if
you start moving to ssds recognizing
there's a cost cost premium there um you
know we find that uh you know the ssds
have their own issues but they're more
reliable to temperature variation
absolutely um but I think that we we
find that we use them for different
things and so if we're going to go out
and build um hundreds of pedabytes of
storage for for Azure storage or for
Bing or something like that the
economics of SSD just break um but uh
they are a little bit more reliable for
temperature variation and there's some
interesting work going on in
understanding exactly how ssds respond
to temperature and what that looks like
from a uh from a drive life perspective
as well as a read WR perspective on on
the type of flash we can
use
so over time things will break
absolutely and do you actually try to go
into these containers and repair things
or do you just at some point
recycle do we yeah so do we do we fail
in place in the containers and forget
about it do you have another question or
no that um so no we don't unfortunately
computers haven't gotten cheap enough
yet um you know there is a the way that
we treat the the containers and actually
the whole environment for that matter is
is about a carefully crafted percent of
the infrastructure that can be down at
any given time and for how long it's
down and then we kind of Target that for
when we're going to go in and repair it
but for right now most of the computer
SL is just a little bit too expensive to
forget about it unless it's right
towards the end of its depreciation
cycle
another you mentioned
thez
gener the heat I know I remember in some
uh newspapers and some I saw that they
are utilizing Heat gener from the faili
to green houses you have any plans to go
um I can't speak to any plans that we
have on that on the drawing boards but
it's it's absolutely a huge opportunity
um and we are looking at it in certain
locations um waste waste heat recovery
for data center is is a great
opportunity um the the challenges are
it's not today it's not quite high
enough grade waste heat like if it was
like three or 400 degrees it's more
portable you can take it somewhere um
but when it's only you know 120 130
degrees it's hard to transfer that into
water and actually move that water a
distance to actually get a huge amount
of benefit from it without putting the
greenhouse right next door not I'm not
going to say that that's out of the
question though question what about
Amazon glacian is a long-term archiving
service sure which is very cost
effective do we have any thoughts on
that I'm sure that someone in the azure
space is considering long-term uh
storage uh there's a number of different
technologies that we could choose from
to do there so can't I can't speak to it
definitively do you think it will be
possible at some point to see the v
machine level the energy consumption of
the machine provide an API for
that um an API to provide to pull the
energy consumption for machine
absolutely um and actually this is kind
of one of the challenges of the overall
OEM e system is that in 1999 I was
buying servers from D HP that had that
Telemetry coming off the hard drive and
the power or off the motherboard and the
power supply already and then somewhere
along the line they wanted things to get
cheaper and cheaper and that was like
one of the first things to go and you're
starting to see those features come back
in natively in the power supply and the
chassis managers and some of the new
products so that that those are there um
in in the higher end products
especially okay I think uh we'll move on
now so thanks David thank you
um so delighted uh to introduce Victor
ball who runs uh mobility and networking
group here I think what's really
exciting is you know we're obviously
talking about Cloud but obviously mobile
devices and services so uh Victor
actually helps really Define the
strategy um of the company on networking
so I'm really looking forward to to
Victor's talk so thank you Victor thank
you
thanks hi
all right uh thank you for giving me
this forum to say a few words
um there there's a lot to say but I'll
try to uh condense it very quickly so um
you know you know and um we have
Microsoft has and Google and Amazon and
everybody spending billions of dollars
on cloud you just heard that talk and uh
it's been going on for many many uh
years and uh so all these companies
including ourselves have been op
optimizing the heck out of uh the cloud
infrastructure itself and now that we
have the both devices and a services
company uh we building both the devices
and the in the uh Cloud but there is
still an open element here that I want
to talk to you a little bit about but uh
just let's uh start with some ground
truths here so we know that in order to
build great Services we need to have uh
the ability to get to those Services
really quickly and and really optimally
and fast and uh the the latency and the
Jitter that you experience is actually
directly will contribute to how you uh
you know uh use your services or how you
think about it
so while we optimizing all the cloud and
uh it is important to sort of think
about how you connect to it all right
and these things matter they matter a
lot I just picked up quotes we have our
obviously our internal uh measurements
as well but I picked up some codes of
people that you might recognize uh
claiming publicly how much it mattered
to their revenue in terms of looking at
something simple as uh latency right so
if you increase the latency to your
services you're actually going to lose
Revenue if you make it better yeah
people are going to come towards you so
we see this again and again both
internally and externally as well so um
I think the more famous code is is from
Marisa Myers which I have listed as
first so now if you think about see as
that component that you want to um to
reduce then let's simplify this problem
I mean you know there's latency in every
part of the system so there's something
going on in the client when the request
is sent then you uh send the request
over the network to the data center it
munges on your data it sends it back the
client PR processes it post process and
presents it to you so there are really
these three components now in the past
um we have focused very heavily on the
data center right in fact Albert is
going to talk next and uh he'll tell you
about some of the innovations that he
himself has been involved with which
include uh removing the network from
being bottleneck to the server so the
servers can now work on line rate and uh
pump data out in line rates and are can
be fully utilized similarly software
load balances and most recently we've
been sort of working on trying to
optimize the bandwidth utilization
between data centers so we've done that
but like I said uh there is a gap and
the Gap has to do with the internet so
no matter how Optimum you are in one
space uh you are not going to really be
able to uh do great sting unless you
sort of think about the internet as well
so this is the talk about that now this
is a little experiment I did a while ago
from my own office this is using uh one
of our phones and it was just a ping a
trace route to one of the Google sites
and you could start to see that
depending on the network I use in case
of Wi-Fi and cellular the number of hops
go up and with the number of hops the
latency to it goes up so now if if you
say I want an SLA I want to build a
service which performs like this CU I
want all the computes to hit me you know
if the if the packets don't even get to
your Cloud you're going to have problems
and we repeat this experiment again and
again and you know we see the same
things now why is this so because the
internet is actually very very complex
right this is a gross simplification of
the internet and what is it it's a bunch
of isps right they talk to one another
they have this nice or bad protocol bgp
and based on policies your package get
routed and at any given point it's not
really clear what route it'll take so if
you don't have any Clarity on what route
it'll take you don't have Clarity on how
many hops it'll take and then you don't
have Clarity on how fast or uh slow
it'll get there are lots and lots of
networks right this is just some data to
sort of show what those networks are now
if you add to that the mobile world
right which is the huge huge deal now
you have great complexity in the mobile
world as well in fact a lot more complex
than the IP world right so the IP is
represented with this little internet
here and a lot of the other stuff is
just mobile and then there's
measurements and you've seen papers you
can see papers which tell you that
latency just goes up this is an a 3G
network you can see T-Mobile with 450
milliseconds this is not uh singling out
any particular uh ISP here but just
general uh measurements and then when
people say well LT is coming LT is a lot
better but there too we see the Jitter
and we see at least 70 milliseconds
average latencies to our data centers
now if you don't believe me you can
actually download this little app that
is available on Windows and phones and
everything else you can try it for
yourself and you will see CU it measure
the latency and you will see all these
numbers are actually absolutely correct
in fact you can start to see how good
your IPS are and what you're getting so
now what is the question the the point
is that when the packet leaves the
device you want it right away you don't
want anything any time spilling the
network is wasted time right so what do
you do you say well we're going to spit
build all these massive data centers all
over the world which is what we're doing
and not just us everybody's doing that
you saw a much nicer picture of this I
just sort of up just uh just a minute
ago or just a speaker before uh but
really we're building all these big data
centers all over the world so that you
can get to these places from wherever
you are very quickly right but is this
really a solution that's enough and the
assertion is that it's not because the
the cost for building these op these
data centers is very large the cost of
both building them and operating them
and you know keep the equipment going
and everything else is very very large
so what's another alternative another
alternative is build lots of these ones
but build slow small of small parts
small of these data centers right so for
example we have a a team called Bing
Edge which kind of does that and then
the idea is that you spread thousands of
these on the internet and then wherever
you are on the network in the world you
get to those guys fast right and then
once you get to those you can at that
point decide what do you want to do with
the packet do you want to compute there
or you want to send it back through some
really good better networking from there
to your mega dat centers and there so
then then systematically you break up
this really complex problem into its
pieces and start to approach each of
these pieces individually okay so that's
and so then like you said like I said
you tunnel tunnel from these micro dat
centers or cloudlets they call in the
literature so these cloudlets what are
these they are much they're capable of
doing a whole lot so right now in this
in the today's world they're really an
SSL termination thing so where and
they're a proxy for Ms services or any
other services that Microsoft runs so
for example you you'll say hit the cloud
and it'll terminate the TCB connection
there and then have a persistent TCP
connection from there uh from The Edge
to the cloud and uh so that way if there
are losses in the TCP those losses get
uh uh you know mitigated not the losses
don't get mated but the delay that
happens because of those losses get
mitigated but then you can also do a lot
of edge Computing stuff this is sort of
new new things you can actually use
these these micro DCS to do resilient
routing so now if one path is not going
well you can create imagine creating an
overlay Network on top of that and start
to send packets around that Network you
can keep doing service and internet
monitoring you don't you can proactively
see if something is going bad or good
and so you can uh uh react to that and
then you can do a tremendously a lot of
uh things for mobile Computing and I'll
give you an example of that so here's
one benefit that I wanted which I think
is fairly significant and you will
appreciate so I don't know how many of
you know but uh when iPhone first came
out in New in uh U several years ago uh
there were lots of these news articles
which said that brought down the New
York uh the networks uh in New York does
anybody remember any of this stuff at
all you remember it so you guys okay so
bad I guess things don't last long but
never there was this big thing which is
that the networks was just brought down
and the question was what was going on
there why did the networks go down well
the way the networks went down is
because everybody iPhone and all
smartphones are trying to save battery
right that's sort of the most and so all
our traffic is very bursty so when you
go to the website you sent a bunch of
packets bunch of package comes and
you're done then you watch the page and
whatever so really what the iPhone guys
were doing at the time was um they would
put the radio on low power mode then
when the data was there to transmit
receive they put it high power mode
transmit the data and as soon as it was
done bring it down to low power mode
makes sense but really that didn't
really work well with the with the Telos
cuz what was happening was that the
whole Telco business is based on circuit
switch networ they come from that piece
of word so every time you set up a
connection a whole set of resources are
set up from your device right onto
entire entire network uh to the uh point
where they go to the internet and so
every time you bring the radio down the
signal is sent bring down the resources
so now as you're going back and forth as
you're as the as you're sending data
back and forth these signals are going
back and forth right and as the signals
are going back and forth the the network
is gets overloaded and can't deal with
it all right so they figured this out
and said okay you can't do that anymore
so so what you have to do now is you
have to when you're done with the data
you can bring it down to lower power so
1.6 uh watts to 1 watt but you can't
really bring it down for an additional n
seconds okay and so if you don't bring
it down then uh you can uh fix any
perturbation and you can sort of solve
this problem a little bit and the energy
is not
lost well so that's a that's the data
here so L consumes about 1.5 Watts but
the chip is active for approximately 10
seconds at one Watt doing nothing all
right now if you have now for imagine if
you have this cloudlet and the cloudlet
is a proxy for your phone so now the
cloudless hold on holds on to your
connection but you tell the cloudlet I'm
done you bring your radio down cloudlet
holds on to the connection which is in
the wide side and you can you know
things things are okay so now if you do
just a little bit of calculation you
find that 1.6 Watts that's here times
whatever speed up because now you're
sending the cloud light you not not
sending it to the or MDC you're not
sending it to the big cloud so that's a
speed uptimes 1 wat * 9 seconds that's
the amount of time you save because now
your radio is down and but you can still
send the package that gives you a saving
of 10.6 Jews this is amazingly
significant saving because if you have
20 Network transfers in let's say one
hour or you know and there may be email
notifications Etc then you can save up
to 26% of your battery okay now no
matter what I mean if you if you're in
the field you already know that energy
management is is amazingly hard this
kind of saving is just incredible right
and if you sort of let that whole thing
keep going and you you know get the
argument if you sort of increase the
number of transactions per hour you
start to see how much saving you can get
from this little thing all right so
having because you now have a cloudlet
uh in the edge now let me show you so
this is pretty pretty good let me show
you one more application and then I'll
be done done so one in this particular
application um you know we talk about
new services and I talked about Edge
Computing and things like that so let's
take something like object recognition
you all heard about argumented reality
you probably work on that um and um uh
object recognition and things like that
so for all of these sort of applications
the building blocks are similar you you
let's say you take face recognition in
this case you detect the face you align
it correct you then extract the features
from the face and then you match those
features to some uh database which will
tell you what those what the face is
right now if you do a lot of this
detection for example just on the client
you take a lot of time here but if you
sent it to the cloud this cloudlet that
I'm talking about then you're serving
less time but what is interesting is
this graph okay so what this graph is
showing is on the horizontal axis is the
time spent on computation on the
vertical AIS is accuracy n is the number
of features that have been extracted so
now depending on how much computation
time you have that many features you can
extract and that'll give you the amount
of accuracy you get and this is true for
pretty much everything that we do with
imaging or Vision or even speech and
even search the graphs look very similar
really the more competition time you
have the better number of features you
can extract the more accuracy you can
get okay now which means that every
second every millisecond that you're
using on the network is wasted
completely waste so all of us all our
companies Microsoft in particular is
very very uh deeply trying to sort of
fix that problem okay let me show you
what it means viscerally so here's a
little thing that my um intern actually
put together and what you see is just to
set it up you see a video of her uh
holding a device and she's taking a
video of people moving and they're just
moving at regular speeds and the system
is using the best face recognition
algorithm that we have uh uh the state
of our uh state um face algorithm to see
if she can detect faces and this is
going to be very fast so you will uh see
how how it goes uh hopefully you'll
catch it so there are seven faces in
here okay uh you'll
see there's seven people walking by
right and we are they taking the video
and doing face recognition on them so
now when you're able to send this data
five to to a Computing device 5
milliseconds away the system is actually
able to recognize all the seven faces
now let's say you put it 75 to 85
milliseconds away the system is going to
try to do the same thing but now it
recognizes only four of the seven faces
okay so because it just can't keep up
and the time that I spent the latency is
lost so now whichever company whichever
one of us actually licks this problem
will obviously you will go towards that
company because now we can even if we
have the best Minds working on this we
really solve the problem because we
fixed the latency issue all right so
there's a whole whole lot of stuff you
can do on the edge I just this is a
laundry list of things you can do a lot
of these are open Problems by the way
it's not necessarily none of these
things are solv but we are working
actively on it I talked about caching
and caching is you know you just you
have the data you just s it SSL
termination you can save a lot of
bandwidth too because uh you can do um
proxying and there are ideas here um not
have time to go through all this stuff
but there's a lot of stuff you can do at
the edge now where do you put these Pro
these clients here's just a couple of
small ideas in a wireless space the way
things work are you've got these dumb
access points and then you got a
wireless switch that's how the wireless
is laid out here that's how Wireless
laid out pretty much in every part of
the world everywhere right so what the
idea here would be that you would attach
an MDC or a cloudlet right next to a
switch once you do that all the packets
that are going in hit this guy and then
he can decide whether it wants to go to
the cloud or not and you can do this own
thing so that's one way to deploy it and
you can go hit every Enterprise every
hotspot pretty much every Hotel
everywhere you want to be okay the same
thing if you think about solell networks
you can do the same thing uh cell
networks are evolving towards what is
called small cells now and small cells
is basically to deal with capacity you
do the same thing you've got a small
cell uh showing up and you put an MDC
there or a cloudlet there and it'll do
the same it'll do the
needful now it's not so you know the
concept of cloudless was uh uh initiated
by us but uh we see now that a lot of
the technical leaders in the rest
different parts of the world are also
starting to talk about it so I just
briefly checked and I found that you
know here are some quotes about people
pretty much saying the same thing here
so uh as you can see in this thing
you've got these devices and you got a
little uh device here sitting on the
edge uh this is from um uh whoever Intel
and this is from Hawaii they're also
talking about they actually use the word
cloudlet here they've got base stations
and then you got everybody talking to
base station at cloudlet which talks to
a cloud this is uh from I think Nokia
Simmons they really put they show a
whole stack here that software stack
that is sitting right here on the edge
as well so this idea this concept is
actually uh has got lots of legs here
and uh there's plenty of literature both
from Microsoft research as well as other
researchers which show that this leads
to tremendous amount of uh
improvements um okay so I'll leave you
with this thought um you know that I
think think in my worldview uh we have
focused very heavily on these large Mega
data centers right and what I'm sort of
talking about now is to create these
thousands of these Micro Data Centers at
the edges now for a company like
Microsoft um we have to now think about
this as a full resource so just as we
look at optimizing the heck out of these
guys we have to now optimize everything
so even if you have put 40 servers per
per rack here and you've got thousand
here you got 40,000 servers that you
have to optimize so now you think about
things like um iot or Internet of Things
internet of things really is about
getting all the data aggregating it
analyzing it doing something with it are
you going to bring all your data here or
you going to just take keep it here and
analyze and send it back here so now you
think about distributed analytics you
think about Hadoop map produce those
sort of things and say is is it how do
how do I think of this entire
infrastructure uh because now the
network is in the middle and I have to
take that into account when I do job
placement and scheduling so as you know
like I said as you think about the cloud
you think about disaggregated Cloud you
start to see that all a lot of the
problems that we have faced in the past
are um are coming back so that's a a
short
talk fantastic Victor and it's good to
see the work we're doing to try and save
on battery life as well as improve
performance so uh let's hope we get
there um so questions from the audience
please yeah
so one advantage of Big Data Center is
you have
a few staff members maintaining very
large number of machines once you go to
this mini data centers then they are
distributed you have maybe a few do
machines in one place a few machine
another place that Advantage
disappears well um so I thought way you
were going with this was uh you were
saying that it's a huge management
headache for a company like Microsoft to
be able to manage because even for us
and and I think part what you're asking
is you've got these uh scales and you
can have this cost benefits but if you
got this disaggregated system then so I
tell everybody here internally that the
world sells the cloud V2 sell the cloud
as computes and storage right what I
want to see is us selling the crowd is
compute storage and latency I want to be
able to give you guarantees that that uh
we can uh not only give you the computer
but we can perform faster so now from
that perspective I think the cost gets
advertised as you start to build this
out and you know as you build the
Technologies out uh in a disaggregate it
should be okay it should not be because
you know it's still there thing I was
wondering how you see this playing in if
at all to like developing
countries and um you know providing
Services there where energy is a bigger
issue as well as as Network SP I think
for developing countries it's actually a
great solution because when you think
about when we think about developing
countries we actually think about um
things like you know electricity not
being there or connectivity but if you
have these micro DCS you can actually
start by building out these micro DCS
infrastructures right they're smaller
they you they can be even one Rack or
two racks maybe they have a you know
some power you can actually deal with
that so this is a good buildup strategy
and when we when you find that the DCS
or micro DCs are not capable of doing it
you start to invest more so to me this
is actually the right way to go in some
of the developing countries CU you can
do you can reach out to a lot of people
with this sort of stuff very
fast what types of locations would you
put them in should they go in like an
office building or just a room somewhere
or right so this is uh uh this is a
slightly longer answer but but um I the
the two examples I gave you I picked uh
easier examples because this that was a
cas where you have an Enterprise and you
you already have power and you already
have this thing but I think what we have
to do to be in all honesty is we have to
uh figure out what is the what reason
man ISP will deploy this so the
traditional reason that people do is
that they uh they say that we can save
you the Upstream bandwidth cost by
cashing a lot of data so once so once we
able to add that value then we suspect
that all these isps that are exist out
there they will find the rack space and
power for for it so the owners is on the
it is on us to sort of figure out what
that value proposition is for these
individuals okay I think we'll uh we'll
move on so thank you Victor it's a real
pleasure to introduce um Albert
Greenberg who was a a researcher here in
Ms it's moved across uh into the Azure
team uh Victor talked about what happens
at the edge um and Albert's going to
talk about really what's happening
inside uh our data centers so to other
great thanks so actually I'm going to
talk about the the work of about 160
Engineers uh who uh are in the um
networking team uh distributed between
Redmond and uh Dublin and Silicon Valley
and the um and what we've done over the
last three years or so um in in uh in
summary um we filled up the network in
the houses that David built and uh these
are houses of glass and copper in uh
lots and lots of glass uh for our
networks um but we've changed everything
I mean there's nothing that was really
not what not a plug or a wire or
anything that hasn't been rethought and
uh that's one of the messages of the
cloud it's just the the uh the scope for
Innovation is so enormous and the like
you could see in Victor's um uh remarks
you know you know uh what seems like you
know just percent um you know one of the
memes you get from uh um you know some
computer science talks if it's not 10x
it's not worth doing but in the cloud
it's not so right because you just get
this incredible multiplier from 5x sorry
5% uh if you can if you can save 5% or
25% or whatever in the power it's
amazing so uh the uh that doesn't mean
we're not aiming for 10x but you um uh
the small gains have terrific
impact so I want to give you a little
bit of uh um Azure by the Numbers just
so you get a feeling for how he grew uh
over and what what scale means uh
somehow physically you have to just get
a you know a sense of what what is scale
here and uh then I I want to talk a
little bit out what um uh these numbers
mean for network and uh you know there's
a company has been purchased for a
billion dollars and this and that so you
probably heard of uh software Define
networks I'm going to tell you kind of
what that's about what it really means
besides it's cool and uh and software uh
defined
storage so um this is a a bit of a dated
picture of uh of uh the footprint of
Windows azure's Mega data centers um
let's see uh 25 data centers and here
I'm not showing the edge that Victor
talked about um a billion customers uh
20 million businesses and uh 75
markets
um it's again I guess just get a feel
for what what is scale you know um maybe
you know a 100 developers sounds like a
lot of people uh but if you if you look
at this kind of growth um it it it's
amazing you you cannot assign a
developer to a cluster or a data center
or whatever there's just we're building
like crazy so in 2010 we had
100,000 uh computer instances VMS and
now we have million
as David said we also have millions of
hosts um the in terms of storage we went
from tens of pedabytes to exites over
those years and in network capacity uh
we went from a kind of a skinny
traditional network of uh tens of
terabits per second to the the pabit per
second networks that we build now in the
data
center um so uh what does it mean if you
want to you know if you're an e Science
Guy or you want want to connect to Azure
and run your your workloads on us or
your your actually Big Data guy whatever
it is you know what what what does it
mean for you uh so the um really what um
uh what cloud providers like Azure
provide is the ability to
create uh in in our environment uh the
the virt from a networking gu point of
view it's whatever virtual Network
Services you want uh so uh we um
uh we allow you to uh first of all with
with high speed I won't be able to talk
about this um extend your private
Network into Azure in a convenient way
Click Boom and you're into
Azure and uh as well as um you don't
have to rewrite your network
architecture you can uh in particular
use the same IP address space the same
kind of network planning tools and
management systems that you're already
using just extended into Azure um so one
way to say say it to Enterprises is that
when they go to build a branch office or
a hub office they can just extend it in
to the cloud if you don't need that then
you can just uh from the beginning build
into the
cloud um but you get a virtual
Network and in essence because of the
way we do compute storage and networking
you get a virtual data center inside a
cloud um okay and then again we this
this picture uh shows that uh we've got
an orange Enterprise and a red
Enterprise and they're completely
isolated even though they're built on
shared infrastructure and they'll feel
like they're dedicated to each customer
the orange customer won't feel the the
presence of the red
customer um so really the uh the
challenge to all of us that are building
uh in the cloud is just how do you keep
up with these
numbers um the uh how do you support for
example 50,000 virtual Networks
uh in a single 100,000 server deployment
in a data
center um and uh really um the answer is
uh I mean honestly uh software um so the
uh uh which which usually starts with
finding the right abstractions and the
right separation of
concerns um one of the
um uh
um you know
sort of natural things for people to
talk about is the hardware um and kind
of the lay of the land I talked about it
myself in the last minutes um but uh the
um uh the software is actually the only
way you can get to this kind of scale
and uh the um what's interesting is also
the the impact it's had on the on the
industry um in you know the the the
industry has put a lot of focus on
network Hardware like switches and
routers and things like that or Optical
networking things and they certainly
have a a major role to play I could show
you some uh data on how we use them but
the the key to this software defined
networking stuff that you hear about and
what everybody is using all the cloud
providers are using is on the host on
the server okay so it's it's not uh it's
not really honestly about just
disaggregating a router it's about new
innovation on the host and host
networking and that's the way you get to
deal with these huge numbers that I'm
talking about in terms of uh data
centers and virtual networks and Beyond
Beyond just the numbers uh by moving
networking down to the host um uh
networking policy down to the host then
you get the flexibility you need to um
to roll out new features and to debug
things um there's no way we could have
changed everything in networking if we
had to wait for a new as6 to get revved
um the uh it it has to happen uh in
software on the host and that's where it
does happen so if you don't remember
anything but this one line to remember
is in the data center the action is on
the
host so um in terms of networking what
does it mean that uh just see about you
think about it uh um uh every host
performs all packet actions on its own
VMS so um that means uh you've you've
got this massively
distributed um uh compute engine uh that
that that works a lot better than if you
try to you know build some kind of
scaleup device that uh that does it uh
in the middle um you know Victor
mentioned our software load balancer we
run software load balancer on every
single um uh device and every single uh
host in in the in the data center so it
it's really this incredible scale out so
it's a massively
distributed uh uh system that's put
together through host networking and
really the the reason it makes sense is
that by Distributing it this way you a
teeny bit of uh Power uh on on each of a
million servers uh uh comes together to
deal with billions of flows and if you
just do the math then each host only has
to deal with a thousand flows So you
you're the right place where you can
apply per flow
policy um and uh so the the essence is
well how do you how do you control that
how do you build a software to um uh to
to deal with all those uh distributed
host and push the software defined
networking to the
host um I just there's really a lot to
say here and um I I just grabbed uh one
slide but now there's a lot of talk
about in the industry open Flow you
probably heard of open Flow and you're
wondering kind of uh is it is it
technically mature is it really a big
deal is it just uh kind of a a hype
thing what is it so uh the essence of it
really is um pretty much that you can
get stuff done through flow tables uh
that are a fairly simple that provide
fairly simple transformation on packets
they move through pipelines and this
happens in a switch that runs on the
host it's called the V switch or virtual
machine switch and by the way it's not
necessarily a layer 2 switch it's doing
a lot of routing um and uh but the the
uh the main thing is that these these
these tables uh can perform uh this
transformation of packets moving through
tables can perform all the networking
functionality you need uh to perform to
get stuff done in networks um and it's I
won't say this is open flow it's um kind
of uh it's similar to the idea of open
Flow and a a lot of a lot of work has
been done at Microsoft uh to make this
kind of idea go really fast and and
scale to huge numbers um so that's this
is kind of the data path mechanism
that's all I have time to show show show
you in this uh little bit but there's
this thing called the controller up
there um that's actually coordinating
policy and programming all these
switches all these you know there's
100,000 switches in the data center so
that thing is not really one thing it's
a distributed system
it's highly highly available highly
resilient and um this combination of the
virtual machine switch and the
controller uh is is what lets you um uh
do software control and and and Rapid
innovation in the data center
Network okay so um I thought uh since um
uh a lot of you guys are interested in
in storage and Big Data i' tell you a
little bit about storage um so just just
like we we have to uh virtualize compute
and virtualize network uh we have to
virtualize storage so there is a uh uh
software defined
storage uh uh industry uh moving in the
in the data center as it turns out uh
storage puts a lot of pressure on the
network sometimes we use the word East
West you know to talk about uh flows
that go from server to server in the in
the network and if you think about one
right in in Azure there some interesting
papers on this that you can find um it
generates a lot of traffic um all around
uh the uh the cluster and the re the
reason is we want to provide amazing
durability we want to uh every bite
written has to be uh quickly accessible
from the compute cluster and has to be
uh you know incredibly durable uh and so
that you know you you won't lose data in
the cloud so we copy it we copy it
efficiently using eraser coding um and
uh so this this generates a ton of ios's
in the in the uh in the cluster and by
the way uh it goes over the wide area
network to other clusters because we
want this uh data to be available even
if this cluster is unavailable uh
because of a fiber cut or what have you
so
um it when you go and do the math of how
you build this this thing it's one of
the fun things about being in the cloud
you can play with any parameter you can
uh put more disc more SSD more bigger
nick uh a bigger switch and so forth but
it turns out at the end of the day um to
make storage cheaper uh you wind up
spending more on
network um and uh not not you know uh um
in a reckless way but in an engineered
way uh you build a bigger Network to
deal with uh the storage one of the
interesting things is um the resurgence
in uh in uh in clouds of RDMA or uh um
which really I uh a few years ago we
didn't think that much about um but uh
really the the great thing about RDMA
Technologies is you get incredible
offloads from the CPU so the uh I mean I
I think you guys that if you're coming
from E science and you've used
infiniband you're used to this that now
now your CPU is basically all your
networking is offloaded to the hardware
and you've got your um uh your CPU back
to do your
computation and uh the um this this is
amazing and I'll show you some uh
numbers about this so um what what we're
able to do uh is uh in the cloud Embrace
um RDMA we use a technology called
routable Rocky um which is an Ethernet
technology that um uh employs infiniband
transport over ethernet um and we've
made we've got it to Route and this is
uh we're working with lots of Industry
Partners on this so um this allows us to
um basically take stress off the servers
these servers are
expensive build a slightly bigger
network with um the right kind of host
support for offloading again host
networking and and get a a more
economical result that meets the needs
of the storage Community um so uh uh the
bottom line is all the logic is in the
host and uh now we have software defined
storage that scales with software
defined
Network um so does it work so there's
just a little uh screenshot that I have
that shows that we're getting line rate
with no
CPU uh zero zero CPU using
RDMA um you know there I didn't want to
just say nothing about physical networks
uh I you know we want these physical
networks to be so so redundant and so
high quality uh that um it's okay if
there's an edge that's broken here and
there and you know there's a packets are
dropping here and there we've got lots
of capacity so uh the the problem
becomes how do we um just disable the
broken piece and you know not have a
panic or a judgment call hey should we
fix this piece or we keep it available
do we have enough remaining capacity we
have enough capacity so that if we can
keep the software and the monitoring and
the Automation and all that stuff
working really really well then the then
uh we have a lot of capacity in the in
the in the physical Network like in uh
this little clo diagram shows uh so that
it's okay for for things to
Break um the the bullet points here have
to do with I guess the I have a this
should be 40 at the bottom um the uh uh
we can get network policy done like
access control lists Network address
translation uh virtual uh private
networks um software load balancing
firewalls all that stuff uh virtual
appliances Network function
virtualization done in the host and then
have this big resilient um uh internal
Network that can do things like RDMA for
example um that uh it just needs to be
very fast converging and um and uh and
Powerful uh all the uh the policy pieces
uh the software the stuff you want to
sort of add new features uh uh within is
uh is in software and we we Implement uh
everything as a VM um and we deploy
Network Services just like any other
service um so let's
see
um uh the um uh just wrap it up at this
point um so uh this um this term of uh
sdn I hope I helped clarify it a little
bit um showed you where we applied
policy to make it happen um and uh the
the other thing that uh it's worth
mentioning is that we are uh you know
bringing the same technology to um a
customer premise uh with our um Partners
in the uh OSG team
okay thanks
Al I was a real really fantastic insight
into what happens inside the data
centers so I certainly found out a lot
that I didn't know about um so uh I'm
sure there's a few questions Dennis do
you want to kick off that was really
fantastic I I get asked by uh people I
work with in the internet 2 community
and they are totally committed to sdn
yeah uh throughout the system he how
when will we be able to actually develop
a couple our sdn clients and the
university community directly into aure
is that something that is foreseeable I
mean they're usually open for right but
that may not be compatible with what we
do so
um I mean really we uh we offer
um uh it there's a there's a there many
there's layers to that question so the
uh um if you uh if you if you want to
build your own uh let's say wide area
network internet too then yeah you can
use uh these kind of ideas uh to to
build your own uh internet too and and
you know we do have an effort to um do
software controlled wide area networks
okay um and uh that's
um uh maybe you know one of the things
that they want to do um but
uh it's um if they instead they you you
know the the idea is you want to bring
your own hypervisor or something uh to
uh to do the kind of host sdn stuff that
I've talked about um the cloud providers
don't provide that kind of bare metal
where you can bring your own hypervisor
you you basically you bring your own
image you're uh you you you if you want
to bring let's say you you like a
certain uh load balancer or something
like that we want to support that as a
service um so you can bring Network
functions but you don't uh um we don't
open up so that you can run uh on the
bare metal um in in our cloud and and no
one I I think does uh to some degree
maybe
um uh you know the hosters do uh that if
you just buy space and and uh then you
can put anything you want in the cage um
uh but um we are I think fairly open
about uh
we uh we we we publish um of what we're
doing so there's that kind of flow of
information but in essence we're telling
people that uh you don't have to do that
uh you um if you want to set up shop in
the cloud and you want to do big data um
you're good I mean and that's uh just
bring bring the data to us and and uh
we'll do the heavy lifting for
you right are there any more questions
yeah maybe this is just more of a
clarification so you mentioned RDMA and
Rocky and all that I understand that was
between the server and your storage will
we be able to get clusters with high
speed
ning yeah so we um yeah this is the
question was did we do that for storage
and and uh and we did um yeah it's one
of the things that we're looking at is
um uh going broader uh with um RDMA than
we we've uh we've done up till now um uh
in in cluster size and also in in field
of
use yeah I think just clarifying that as
well on on Azure that we've now got the
a A9 instances for for True
HPC um with infin band uh running
Windows HBC uh and we've seen some
benchmarks that show actually from uh
one of the universities in Switzerland
which is that's running faster than
their local HPC cluster so I think we
we're starting to to to experiment with
that and we do have a service
um but rolling that out more broadly I
think is something say product teams are
are looking at yeah but actually is that
I was under the impression that we
didn't have access to that through our
University Research as allocation yeah
the the Azure awards are for particular
types of instances but I think if you
want to um play around with the the
windows HPC talk to us Dennis uh you
know we're interested to see what what
people are looking for but as I said
I've just literally just last week seen
some benchmarks uh from a university in
Switzerland and they're looking to just
use wind use Azure HBC rather than their
own local HBC um for a lot of their
workloads so
yeah are there any more
questions okay well thank you Albert
that's
fantastic Jonathan uh Goldstein who's
who's one of our researchers here who um
did go off into product land but uh came
back
um is going to talk um about sort of e
science he's um one of our experts in
Big Data um we had a session yesterday
around streaming data um and I think
that's something dear to Jonathan's
heart he's one of the people who uh sort
of came up with the ideas around um
stream insights which is uh one of our
products uh I'll just switch the power
point
go that one isn't it
we
go does this
work yeah I think so okay so uh yeah say
thanks Jonathan hello everybody so today
I'm going to uh so the title of the
session was the leading uh the Leading
Edge of the cloud right so I I thought
it would be worthwhile talking about um
how this relates particularly to e
science how we got to where we are why
the gaps are that are there and what the
gaps are that are likely to close and
what are ones that you know maybe we
don't have good answers for yet um so so
first of all where is the Leaning Edge
right so the cloud was originally built
basically to serve web pages and to
solve the search and the online
advertising problem right so basically
the cloud sort of cloud V1 was basically
designed to solve these two problems uh
so what does that mean well it means
that that the cloud was built for
serving you know that uh the cloud was
built to handle human generated request
response
uh kinds of workloads where there was
some kind of state being stored in the
cloud so you had essentially think of it
as you know billions of devices which
are people very slowly entering data uh
into the cloud which would then be
accumulated somehow into some kind of
state and possibly served back right uh
the other aspect of it is that part of
solving the problems related to online
advertising and search involved being
able to solve uh very large data
processing problems uh that required
massive scale out now the the thing that
motivated all of this activity was that
we knew in advance that solving this
problem would be worth more than10
billion right so having very expensive
infrastructure as a critical thing to
solve this problem was okay it wasn't it
wasn't a problem um the other aspect is
uh this sort of Ubi ubiquitously
connected queri ability and result
dissemination it's connected to the
internet right so everybody can get web
pages everybody can search everybody can
do all of those things um the other
thing is is that there was some sense of
sort of pay as you go infrastructure uh
you know the more people that connected
and and used your website the more
expensive it was going to be to do but
the Assumption was that you were going
to make that money back and you wanted
that sort of scalability as people used
it the ramping up to be transparent and
and and easy so the question is does
this sound like you right as e
scientists right does this sound like
you so let's take apart each of these
things separately uh the first thing
let's talk about the human generated
request response right so science e
science things tend to have more massive
data rates from a smaller number of
sensors right so that doesn't really
sound like you guys right the uh uh
another thing that's worth saying is is
that it's true that that I think the
massive scaleout aspect of things is in
common because you have very large data
sets uh that you want to process
uh but the thing is there's an unknown
payoff I think it's pretty well known
it's
zero well the hope is that eventually it
will pay off in some way which is why
NSF funds it and you know it'll help
Society eventually right but but the
point is you don't know at the beginning
what the maybe it's going to be big
right maybe the payoff is going to be
gigantic maybe it'll be nothing maybe
it'll turn out you don't find anything
you just don't know right the other
thing is this sort of combination of U
ubiquitous connectivity and the Pay As
You Go part and and if if you ask me I
think the reason you folks are really
interested in the cloud is because of
all the yellow stuff it's it's because
it's connected to everywhere so
everybody can share data sets can run
queries against them can share results
can reproduce them uh all of that along
with the fact that oh wow you know
there's this opportunity to get a hold
of a supercomputer um that we can all
share to to basically do computation I
think these are the main reasons but
those other thing there these
differences right so let's stick again a
little bit deeper um so so let's talk
about the human versus machine generated
you know aspect of things um there's you
know a vast increase in the data rates
per source for for E scientists right
it's not somebody clicking on a web page
it's some sensor that's constantly
reporting a result maybe even video
right um there's a significant but
smaller decrease in the total number of
sources you probably don't have 5
billion of these things one for every
person on the planet you probably have
you know anywhere between tens to
hundreds of thousands of these things
would be my guess um the the other thing
is it's worth saying though that the
decrease in the number of sources uh is
is not doesn't compensate for the data
through put so frequently you end up
with uh uh vast differences in the data
scale you look at something like the
amount of data that the Hadron Collider
and there is no business I'm aware of
that produces data where anywhere near
those kinds of quantities um the the
other thing is that none of the data
sources are part of the data center this
turns out to be pretty important because
you have to get your data into the data
center somehow in order to to operate on
it usually these are sensors that are
somewhere in the world collecting data
about something the aggregate amount of
data that they all produce is pretty
large if you look at the online
advertising case yeah it's true that
like clicks and things like that in
Search terms came from the outside but
there's also a lot of data that was
collected inside the data center itself
that was then logged so a lot of the
data in that case was actually born
inside the data center in the first
place in in this case actually none of
it is right so you know all of this adds
up to big a big data Ingress problem for
scientific data right now now the good
news is that there is a solution to this
problem right and Jim Gray suggested it
to to my knowledge uh the first I heard
of it many years ago which is you
collect the data on some kind of medium
could be a hard drive could be whatever
the future holds right and then the idea
is once you collect the data and you
store it there you ship it directly to
the data center and just physically
attach it right and the assumption is
that you collect it on a medium that's
amenable to later data processing that's
pretty important uh so that uh because
because copying this data this is large
amounts of data copying it moving it
over a network this just is not a
sensible thing to do there's another
alternative in China the Beijing
genomics Institute build the data center
around the sequen so I was going to I
was going to hold that uh yes you're
right there there is actually and this
actually plays in a little bit to what
Victor was saying saying possibly too
right which which is that one
possibility is to bring the data to the
data center another possibility is to
bring the data center to the data right
so you can kind of go in either
direction um bringing the data center to
the data has its own set of problems but
neither of these are e are super
straightforward so Microsoft can build a
telescope yeah
exactly um so so let's go into this a
little bit more right about this whole
um uh uh the nature of of the sort of
the lucrative aspect of online
advertising compared to this kind of
exploratory you know aspect of data
science well so I just have you know
four quadrants here um the top two are
are the high investment quadrants the
bottom two are the low investment
quadrants and then we have the the left
quadrants which are the low return and
the right is the high return the current
cloud computing infrastructure which was
built to solve search and online
advertising um is clearly in in the high
investment High return category right
the problem with escience is that well
we don't really know it depends on the
activity and you don't know in advance
exactly where you are now to make
matters worse uh the very high return
that we got for online advertising it
was so high it was such a valuable
problem to solve that it allowed us to
be incredibly wasteful uh with the
resources the Computing resources that
we use to solve the problem problem and
time to Market ended up being a lot more
important than whether or not you were
efficiently using the resources that you
had in order to sort of get a grip on
all of that so Hadoop can process about
1 to 10 megabytes per node per second
right that's about what Hadoop can do
now everybody's excited about spark
because Spark's a lot better right so
spark can do maybe 5 to 50 megabytes per
node per second that's a lot better
that's a five times increase in
throughput right we must be doing great
right spark must be great right well
maybe not uh by comparison main memory
databases can process very similar
queries at rates of about 1 to 10
gigabytes per second per node so we're
talking about a difference in levels of
efficiency between 100 and a th factor
it's huge so it takes a thousand Hadoop
nodes to do what one of these can do in
a single Noe right so that's a level of
inefficiency that's pretty
staggering now if you need 100,000
machines to solve your online
advertising problem and your online
advertising problem is worth $10 billion
you shrug your shoulders and say oh well
I'll just go ahead and do it anyway
because I know how to scale that up to
100,000 nodes I don't know how to scale
up that technology to 100 notes so I'll
just pay the price and and ow well right
but does this sound like a recipe for
success for an exploratory data
processing task where you don't know in
advance what the return is going to be
does it make sense even to spend that
money right
and now now it is worth saying that this
these databases that I'm talking about
have limitations right they're they only
allow you to express certain kinds of
queries and I think that actually a very
rich area of work uh which actually is
the area I'm I'm working on right now uh
is is basically saying you know how can
you reduce this efficiency Gap while at
the same time uh not limiting yourself
to the expressiveness that these
database engines have and and
significantly expanding the scope of the
kinds of computations that they can do
enough uh so that uh they're useful to e
scientists right there's a lot of a lot
of ground to make up here right now
unfortunately the bad news is that we
may ultimately be limited by the by
networking right it's we're saying that
today's technology for these inmemory
DBS is 1 to 10 GBS per second but with
you know the new Sandy Bridge uh
architectures that are going on and all
the uh uh improvements in in processor
in microprocessor and uh computer design
we have every reason to believe that in
the pretty near future the 1 to 10 is
going to turn into 10 to 100 so you know
10 to 100 Gig gigabytes per second we
all feel like we'd be doing really well
if we maxed out our 10 gbit Nick you
know inside the data center so that's so
there there may be a one to2 order of
magnitude difference between the
throughputs that you can get sending
data from machine to machine uh versus
the kind of bandwidth that you can get
between main memory and your
microprocessor so it may be that that
those that networks will fundamentally
limit us
here now the the good news is that the
ubiquitous you know sort of connectivity
and the pay as you go aspect of it well
that's kind of motherhood and apple pie
for everybody so uh I I think actually
our current data centers do a pretty
good do a pretty good job there um now
there there's one other axis of
difference I was just talking to Ed
Lasser before this and there's one other
AIS of difference that he pointed out
that I think is worth mentioning which
is data longevity right which is to say
the online advert in the online
advertising problem once data was a year
old no one cared about it anymore it
really had no relevance anymore for
either search or for PE the behavior of
people for ads and all these kinds of
things um so really data just kind of
got thrown away you know after a year or
so uh you know Ed pointed out that that
a lot of scientists want to keep their
data for something like 50 years um and
as time goes on there's may be reason to
believe that that it'll just sort of
continue to be valuable over those 50
years so that's you know that's also an
important part of that now my suspicion
I was thinking about that and my
suspicion is that that problem probably
will get solved just because companies
are incredibly paranoid about losing
data so they may in fact in this whole
service thing Force us to cope with that
problem anyway uh just of their own
internal paranoia so uh that may be that
problem there may be significant Market
pressures for us to address that
problem so that is my talk and if
anybody has uh any questions in part
this was designed to spark a
conversation so so feel free to to jump
in and I I want to hear opinions and and
um and
comments thank you
John controversial things in there I
think so has anyone got any comments
does anybody agree or disagree with
Jonathan I mean I very much agree with a
uh with a point that for a lot of
scientific data uh we cannot build a a a
data center where the data coming from
we actually have to get the big problem
is getting the data to the uh to the
cloud and with that comes also a trade
of not only of um how do you use the
cloud but do you use infrastructure as a
service how much of it do the locally is
still with whatever biggest computer you
can get versus on the cloud and this
Traders I don't think we we've explored
yet enough of of what's worthwhile and
the the when you actually have to pay
the cost of getting data to the cloud
yeah it does kind of feel like there's a
there's sort of a big discontinuity
between you know I can run my data on my
machine and in whatever my version is of
my local in memory DB that I can get
really good performance on once my once
the dat data kind of reaches a certain
size where it starts getting really
difficult you know or nonsensical to do
that at one at some point you have to
sort of bite this bullet and pay this
price and say you know oh well I'm going
to flip a switch now and put this data
up in the cloud um that's a hard switch
to flip is I think that's kind of your
point is is that it's it's not it
doesn't it doesn't feel like there's any
sort of Continuum there's sort of this
hard switch that you have to flip right
it's also not like it at least I don't
well understand yet the tradeoffs of
sort of the the expense of getting the
data there the computational the the
infrastructure is a service uh you know
the computation as a service and so on
all these trade ups are not clear of
what what should we put on the cloud
clearly if we want to share data we
should put some part part of those data
on the cloud clearly if your data is are
big you should put some part you should
put your data on the cloud but um at
what point should we add computation you
know to go with it versus do some of it
locally what are the trados it just I I
wonder a little bit whether what Victor
talked about uh you know whether his his
sort of uh microc clouds uh were could
sort of help with things like that
because maybe that can give you more of
a Continuum and and and maybe if it's
even something that can be on premise
you can become part of the cloud or
something like that I know it's kind of
some SP Sparks some thoughts for me
around maybe the cloud doesn't have to
be this this totally monolithic thing
where
you know you send your data there and
it's this big thing you have to do maybe
you can bring it to maybe you can bring
it to your to your data in pieces as you
need to or something like that Jeffrey
listen to one of the other talks why
can't we use um sdn and RDMA to link our
data in our local data directly to aor I
think that's what how it was showing and
it's actually something we've been doing
with Janet in the UK where we've got now
a dedicated 10 gbit per second
direct connection into our Dublin data
center from Janet so all of the UK
universities now and this is just I
think it just went live uh we haven't
made a big Public Public Announcement
we've been working with Janet for about
the last 18 months on this where we have
a dedicated private Network line between
the UK academic Network and our Dublin
azile data center at 10 gbits per second
and so again we are trying to work with
the research Community to look at this
and very much with the AZ for research
program as we've now getting towards 152
200 projects it's interesting the hybrid
approach of local plus public is
certainly something that we're seeing uh
and I think as Microsoft as an
organization that is our strategy as a
company really is hybrid uh and so yeah
why can't we just ask internet too I
don't want a dedicated line why can't I
ask internet to to take my um
local you know my local Computing or my
local storage and connect it in this SE
as fion to a using host sdn
and was what's what's what's wrong with
that so next next month is Tera which is
the international national research
Network Conference and last year at Tera
they did you know all of the talk was
about stn sdn all of the national
research networks not just internet 2
but the other ones and not just you know
other us um Network providers not you
know um like in California so so I think
sdn actually is something that all of
the national research networks are
moving towards and and you know we are
working with them um surfnet in the
Netherlands where we have an Amsterdam
data center for instance I think you
know as well just from you from the
research Community if we know that
that's what you need uh then that helps
us to talk to the National research
networks
Jeff so are are we making are we fooling
ourselves a little bit by focusing on
these immense data sets you know like
the national ignition facility generates
a terab you know in some number of NS
okay well OB obviously the networks
can't handle that but but a a big data
set at least in my terms are are the
satellite data you know satellite images
well you know we we get the data down
from the
satellite right and and
so you know if we can get data down from
the
satellite it it should a problem to get
those data onto a disc somewhere right
so so the question is what kind of
throughput what kind of throughput are
we talking about we're talking about
um you know sort of 100
meab bit per second sort of 100 megabit
per second so like 10 megabytes per
second or something like that yeah that
that seems to me like that's something
you could thing is is that it's you know
it does go on 24/7 right but but but on
the other hand you
know we have we have communication
satellite the data come down but you
know what I think frequently happens in
fact people that are really interested
in low latency build their own receiving
station so so there's sort of two two
comments the the first is that I think
part of the part of the problem that
people face when they have things like
that is that everybody everybody knows
satellites are expensive and everybody
knows that launching satellites are
expensive so when they kind of budget
these things they they they say you know
oh okay well I have this much money to
sort of launch my satellite and develop
my satellite and and all of that they
don't necessarily budget in all the
things that people are going to want to
do with the data once they have it right
so so you know the question is if you
want to if you want to keep this data
for 50 years and you want to allow
somebody to to run queries against it
part of it is this collection thing this
continuous collection thing but then
even after after you've collected it
that somebody has to continuously pay to
curate it and and keep it available for
everybody so that they can essentially
answer questions with it and that's an
ongoing cost that never really ends and
it needs to be the question is who pays
for it does the person who puts the
satellite up there pay for it does the
person who who runs the computation task
pay for it um be because if it's the
person who runs the computation task for
instance then okay now who pays for data
curation so has to be some kind of
business story around it's worth it for
me to curate this data because I'm
confident that people are going to to
come to it and ask questions which I can
then charge them to produce answers for
or something like that and well but I I
guess there's so so first of all there
is an archive that that is paid for by
the
taxpayer so that archive so my point is
if that archive is a bunch of offline
tapes for instance then it's not really
very useful in that form if I'm going to
run a query against it now suppose I
want to get that data and run a query
against it and it's and it's pretty
large it may only be 10 megabytes per
second but now accumulate that over 10
years right that's actually like a
fairly significant amount of data well I
guess so be one of the issues though
is it's it's somewhat like a model
computation in that in that it is
recoverable all right and so
uh years ago during the seoa 2000
project Joe pasquali kind of looked at
this issue of you know there's a cost to
store there's a cost to compute in this
case there's a cost to retrieving it yep
from from another archive and and based
on
usage and and some cost tradeoffs you
can kind of decide when you can get R
when you can throw data
away
because if in principle it's recovered
right and and in the end I I think it
all goes back to that it it all goes
back to economics in the end right I
mean you hold on to the data if you if
you hold on to the data in queriable
form if you think it's going to be
valuable enough to make it worth your
while to hold on to it and then
disseminate it for tasks where you think
that the expected return warrants the
cost that you're going to pay um you
know or something like that right and
and it is fuzzy because it's science and
we don't always know we don't know what
the outcome is going to be in advance
right but these are like very critical
these are very critical problems we have
to solve you know as part of solving
this larger problem we have to really
think through this stuff very carefully
about you know who curates the data and
why and make sure they're motivated in
what form is the data is it is it very
cold is it clo is it warmer do I have it
spinning in discs somewhere them ready
to query you know just in case somebody
I mean somebody needs to decide all
these things and there and and you can't
divorce it from the economics I guess
that's partly what I'm
saying yeah I think that's one of the
things that like the res the research
data Alliance is trying to Grapple with
that globally right across all the
disciplines and a lot of these questions
are common across GE
Sciences them absolutely and and sort of
version one of the internet you of the
of the of these clouds actually the
economics weren't aligned I think with
what with what scientists would like
and I I think that's changing I think
it's it's there's enough motivation to
to go after problems that aren't just 10
billion doll problems that efficiency is
mattering now I mean you saw the number
of customers we want to support in a we
are supporting in Azure and I guarantee
you there's 10 times more than that that
we want to support and we won't be able
to lure them you know onto our Cloud
without addressing these efficiency
problems but the original problem that
motivated our Cloud design was one that
had such a high level of return that it
allowed us to not worry about efficiency
to a pretty large degree I think I'm
just going to um I think there's a lot
of interesting disc discussion here that
um would be good to continue over lunch
so um uh I know Jeffrey did you have a
quick one or is it is this a lunch
discussion maybe it's a l in the bar I
had a I was at some meeting about
scientific Network and I asked the
people there that um as far as I can see
scientist data was an natur neurable
fraction of the total amount of data and
so why on Earth do we need special
resources because with within some
fluctuations therefore it ought to be
possible not to have special programs
and just solve it on top of the
commercial
infrastructure and they did not like my
question but know that they actually
answer my
question but but actually I saw the
numbers that it's exactly the other way
around that scient ific there is more
scientific data sheering numbers that
today that's produced by so I think this
is though right what we do when we want
to make scientific data look really big
we site about three or four projects and
when we want to make it look small we
site the other 99.9% of the project the
the total amount of data is meant to be
four zetes and the LHC is 10 or 100 this
is aable
fraction strong but I say even if you
grant it maybe maybe there of these
projects are producing a lot you ignore
those stle projects that they going to
do their own thing anyway I'd like to
speak I sort of agree that we the rest
of the projects could be handled in the
noise perhaps Dennis do you want to wrap
up I just was to say Facebook delivers
more photographic images to people in a
day than uh than LC is generating in its
entire
lifetime there is far more
non-scientific data than there is but
the total amount of data is a lot less
important then the variety of tasks and
the value of those tasks um that people
want to do with the data right the
network the
network depends on how much you move it
it does I think this is definitely
sounds like a lunch
time thank you all the speakers in the
panel and we'll reconvene at half
f